people with multiple sclerosis who've  been told they have to be on medications  for their civilized they're okay without  medication now and they have no symptoms  people with rheumatoid arthritis the  same thing why because they got in touch  with their real cells they stop  suppressing themselves they stop trying  to please everybody else they said who  am I what do I need what are my  interests what I'm what I need to say no  to what I need to say yes to a lot of  these conditions  who are which are considered to be  chronic and incurable  they're not illness is a manifestation  of a person's trauma and a person's life  and if you turn that life around you can  very often have a positive impact on the  illness as well right